Follow me on Instagram at David Pakman.
For the latest on my very safe socially distance
in-state vacation here in Martha's Vineyard.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.
Welcome back to the David Pakman show.
OK, I don't want to spend like a crazy amount
of time on this story today because it's not
that it's not a huge story.
It is a huge story.
But I believe that this story is ultimately
going to do very little in terms of moving
the needle towards the goal of removing Donald
Trump because his followers have been primed
to dismiss stuff that isn't good for Trump
as fake news.
But it is an important story.
So let's discuss it a little bit and maybe
later in the week we'll have more more information
about it over the weekend.
News reports came out that Russia was offering
bounties and death.
That means it's like a cash bonus, right?
Bounties were being offered by Russia to Taliban
linked militants for killing American soldiers
and coalition forces in Afghanistan.
And there's a lot here.
Historically, Russia's political links to
Afghanistan go back a very long time.
Both Democrats and Republicans in the United
States have had any number of abortive ventures
into dealing with Afghanistan from a geopolitical
standpoint.
But the facts here are really about what Trump
knew, if he knew it and when he knew it.
And this allegedly was happening behind the
scenes.
Russia offering bounties on killing U.S. and
coalition forces in Afghanistan while Donald
Trump was publicly sucking up to the Russian
president, Vladimir Putin.
And the story goes that months ago, American
intelligence agencies concluded that a Russian
military intelligence unit was offering secret
cash bonuses for killing these coalition troops,
which include American troops.
And this made it, we know, to the National
Security Council by March of this year, meaning
we'll talk later about what Trump knew and
when he knew it.
But at minimum, it made it to the National
Security Council.
The allegation, certainly in other countries,
like in the U.K., they were also aware at
the highest levels of their government and
intelligence services about these alleged
cash bounties for killing their troops.
And that leaves us with two possibilities
about Donald Trump possibility.
One is Trump knew about this at the time and
he was still sucking up to Putin or Trump
didn't know about this at the time, which
means someone has to get fired for keeping
the president in the dark about something
so major.
But I'll tell you how it's all being spun
and we may or may not really figure out what's
going on.
So if Trump was not briefed about this alleged
cache bounty, if he didn't know, that's a
major problem, because we know it was discussed
that the National Security Council level.
And we know that our allies were aware of
it so that the initial question was, does
Trump know?
The White House said nothing for the first
24 hours after this story broke.
No comment.
And then the White House and Trump seemed
to coordinate the response that Trump had
no idea.
Trump hadn't been told.
He just wasn't aware that this was going on.
But again, Trump always has to go a little
bit further.
And Trump starts to imply he wasn't told because
it's fake news, which is just absolutely perfect
for his supporters who have been primed to
believe exactly this.
Donald Trump tweeting, quote, Nobody briefed
or told me Vice President Pence or Chief of
Staff Mark Meadows about the so-called attacks
on our troops in Afghanistan by Russians,
as reported through an anonymous source by
the fake news, New York Times.
So understand that first Trump is misstating
the story.
The story is about Russian bounty's Russian
bounty's, if, indeed troops are killed.
It's not necessarily a story about Russian
attacks, although there could have been some.
He again brings up the anonymous source thing
as reason to think that it's all fake news.
He goes on to say, everybody is denying it
and there have not been many attacks on us.
Nobody's been tougher on Russia than the Trump
administration with corrupt Joe Biden and
Obama.
Russia had a field day taking over important
parts of Ukraine, whereas Hunter probably
just another phony times hit job, just like
their failed Russia hoax.
Who is their source?
So this is like the standard operating procedure
for Trump.
Trump calls the attacks so-called.
He again says it's all based on an anonymous
source.
Can't trust that attacks Obama and Biden and
brings out the fake news moniker.
So we don't actually know the truth.
If Trump was briefed and just decided to say
he wasn't, well, then he's a liar.
But we already know that he's a liar.
So that wouldn't be new if Trump was briefed
but forgot, which we've heard.
Trump has no memory to speak of what?
So ever that again raises the cognitive decline
and fitness for the job.
Sorts of questions.
And then if Trump really was not briefed,
which is the story they are telling us.
Don't heads need to roll?
Don't people need to be fired for not briefing
the president about this?
Maybe not, because their new position, as
I alluded to, is the reports while discussed
by the National Security Council, were so
unbelievable, so not credible that it didn't
make sense to brief the president.
To which I say that's absolute B.S..
I mean, that's just absolute B.S.
If it gets to the NSC and they determine we
don't think this is true.
You still brief the president on it.
Unless again.
If you don't brief the president because you
want plausible deniability, if you want to
hide the president from this so that he can
later deny having knowledge of it.
That's a whole other set of problems.
Remember Benghazi, the endless bogus hearings
that uncovered nothing.
This actually warrants hearings and actually
warrants putting people under oath so we can
figure out was Trump told or was Trump not
told?
Who's lying?
Where is the responsibility?
I wouldn't be shocked to hear that officials
under oath would testify.
You know, we we did tell Donald Trump whether
or not Donald Trump listened because he's
often watching a TV in the background while
he's getting his presidential daily briefings.
Whether Trump remembers.
That's a separate question.
They are for now insisting on Trump did know.
That's a terrible defense.
It's the one that you maybe put out there.
If the truth is even worse, as is often the
case with this administration, hopefully we'll
learn more about this in the coming week.